good evening everybody
and i welcome you to this free webinar
on transcriptomic data analysis for
cancer research
today's webinar will introduce you to
our upcoming workshop starting on april
23rd
to april 24th that will introduce
clinicians and researchers to the
invaluable resources
and big data analysis tools that can
help them get
insights into cancer biology
this two-day workshop is organized by
experts in bioinformatics and
computational biology
from pine biotech and dr samya ranjan
malik assistant professor of the
department of pathology
all india institute of medical sciences
new delhi
precision medicine as we know is
changing the way we
understand diagnose and treat cancer
this transformation is driven by high
throughput molecular data
from patients animal models and large
scale experiments
one such repository that has gained
prominence for cancer researchers around
the world
is the cancer genome atlas or the tcga
in this multi-center collection of
patient samples one can find multi-omics
data
and clinical metadata from thousands of
patients
across many clinical pathologies and it
will be the focus
of our conversation in this workshop
this workshop will be guided by
professor manoj kumar singh
head of pathology at ames new delhi and
elia brodsky
ceo and co-founder of pine biotech usa
the workshop will introduce you to the
user-friendly big data analysis tools
curated
ngs transcriptomic data sets and methods
of biological
interpretation for molecular signatures
associated with cancer clinical
pathology we will learn about the
important project
and the data it contains to learn to
navigate the
cancer data repositories to find
multi-omics datasets with clinical
information about the samples
one of the tools that we will be using
in the workshop is the tbio info
platform
this cloud-based platform is designed
with a vision to make bioinformatics
accessible and useful without
unnecessary complications that
exclude non-experts and make
conventional tasks extremely burdensome
the participants of the program will be
able to use this omix logic resource the
tbi
info platform for a hands-on practical
environment to learn and apply advanced
analytical methods to large data sets
and use them in basic and
translational research as a result of
completing the training in the
specialized workshop participants will
be able to process
explore visualize and analyze
transcriptomic data from patients to
find associations with clinical staging
treatment and outcomes we welcome you to
join the program and earn a certificate
of participation from
ames new delhi and prime vibe
now let me introduce you to the mentors
of the workshop we have from our team dr
harpreet kaur who is our omix logic
trainer
and expert by information she guides
the mentor sessions and help
participants with their projects
her area of specialization is in cancer
genomics
dr mohit mazumdar has a phd in
computational biology and over 10 years
of experience working with
industry and academia
he also guides the student projects and
helps participants
understand how to go forward with their
research
we have dr samiranjan malik who is the
associate professor
at ames new delhi dr sudhir verma who is
an application
scientist and clinton kunha from our
team who is a bi-informatics trainer
and now i would want to invite elia
brodsky
our ceo and co-founder at pine biotech
to talk more about
precision oncology and cancer research
over to you india
heidi you're muted
thank you and uh welcome everyone to
this webinar
my name is elia brodsky and i have had
the privilege of running
hundreds of online and on-site programs
in bioinformatics
with our collaborators at georgetown
university louisiana state university
tulane university of haifa and many
others and so as a result i have seen
hundreds of students
clinicians and researchers from many
different backgrounds complete their
online training
and get empowered by bioinformatics
tools to participate in research studies
develop data-driven hypotheses for their
projects and go on to publish
or present their projects in poster
review sessions
as well as review
peer-reviewed journals and so what i
want to share with you today is a little
perspective
on how bioinformatics and specifically
in this era of next generation
sequencing
the analysis tools for different types
of genomic and transcriptomic data
can really make a difference in our
understanding of
cancer and cancer specificity to the
various
regions that you probably are located in
and so to briefly talk about that i want
to start by talking
about the cancer genome atlas
so as you know the cancer genome atlas
represents
a unique and tremendous effort of
understanding of molecular drivers of
cancer
across many types of tumors tissues and
different types of patients of different
ages
and of different backgrounds we can also
see the impact of
treatments treatment combinations and
comorbidities
and this effort which was led primarily
by the us
and eventually also expanded to canada
has led to really a revolutionary
revolutionary impact on the fight to
cure
cancer and so what you can find
in the tcga are uh many different
samples that essentially are already
sequenced and processed and ready to be
analyzed and this comes with a lot of
metadata information that is important
for us to understand
who is this related to and how and so
the impact of tcga
has been really tremendous
there are many different uh canonical
substitutions and indels
dna alterations mutations that have been
detected
in various types of cancers including
many novel types such as fusions copy
number
alterations and complex structural
variations and this has been only
possible
as a result of this large scale
collection of data
there are already known aberrations in
gene expression
different types of epigenetic regulation
with micrornas and long non-coding rnas
as well as methylation
and we have been able to map a lot of
those to protein expression and
structure changes
that were implicated with functional
consequences
at the same time cancers of different
tissues were found to share
some same alterations and to be
biologically more similar to each other
than to other tumors of same
tissue and origins for example breast
cancer
and endometrial cancers and so this new
discovery
has really changed our understanding of
tissue specificity for different types
of tumors
we know that tumors are diverse
populations of cells that composed of
cancer clones and immune cells of
various heterogeneity
and so established there has been an
established
genomic data resource for the broad
research community to study this type of
variation
uh so uh there has been also a
tremendous
impact on the field of bioinformatics as
a result of tcga because so much data
has been collected
in such quantities and such detail that
researchers are developing
new tools for a wide range of purposes
for example calling somatic and germline
mutations
predicting genes of prognostic
significance
constructing regulatory networks
analysis of batch effect and correction
and automated analysis of cancer images
and all of this has to do with a routine
use of tcga data
that is guiding health and science
technologies
now the objective of tcga was to help
lead a substantial improvement in data
quality
and reduction in cost for dna and rna
sequencing and
importantly it has really achieved that
by demonstrating
the value of such omics data for cancer
research
many new types of assays and arrays have
been developed as a result of this
effort
and other molecular technologies have
seen a substantial growth investment
and use and so really the way that tcga
has affected
the way that cancer patients are treated
in the clinic
by understanding the molecular drivers
of disease
and linking it to clinical markers that
we can identify
and so there has been more accurate
stratification and prognosis of disease
that can be provided through molecular
and clinical data integration
specifically in the case of low-grade
gliomas in gastric cancer
and many molecular subtypes of cancer
now can be treated by available drugs or
have the potential to be investigated
for
treatment and so some of these have been
um impacting uh the types of cancers
that are primarily prevalent in the west
because cancer is the second
most uh prevalent uh uh
cause of death around the world um
which affects almost 10 million people
dying from cancer per year around the
world
cancer prevalence is the greatest in the
western world
with close to six percent of people
having cancer during their lifetime in
the us
approximately 39 of men and women around
the world will be diagnosed with cancer
at some point during their lifetime
and over 16 000 children and adolescents
aged 0 to 19 will be diagnosed with
cancer
and 1730 will die of disease according
to 2019 data
however data shows that
cancer especially affects aging
population so the aging is associated
with
a lot of mutations that naturally occur
as the cells divide called somatic
mutations
and so naturally this type of effort to
sequence
and understand genomic drivers of cancer
have
traditionally been focused on what we
observe in the western population
however many novel research studies
are identifying very unique and specific
differences
in cancer driving genes and alterations
between the western and the eastern
populations where actually the profiles
of cancer
could be very different and one of the
things that we have
already seen in the clinic is that the
major
impact of treatment can be
changed as a result of early detection
and so this ability to screen
for early signs of cancer biomarkers
that
help us understand the molecular drivers
of a particular condition
have really changed the impact of
clinical treatment of cancer in the west
and so
we hope that through the ability to
collect
more data in the east in asia and in
other places around the world
will also lead to early screening and
early diagnosis of cancer
that prevents the later stage
manifestation of cancer
such as metastasis and late stage
cancers that essentially
are very hard to be treated and even
when the treatment happens
it has low effect and does not prolong
the life
but significantly reduces the quality of
life
one of the findings that is important
because of this next generation high
throughput sequencing of data
is the discovery that many cancers are
actually
caused by viral infections and so if a
human tissue sample
is subjected to whole genome sequencing
viral dna that might be infecting cells
in that sample will also get sequenced
and this provides us with a fantastic
opportunity to collect data to find new
associations between
viruses for example detection of
particular viruses
but also characterization of those viral
genomes
and their own mutations and
recombination
with particular types of cancers as well
as different
outcomes as we all know the hpv vaccine
for example has had a
profound effect on the impact of cancer
globally
but many other cancers like the
epstein-barr virus
in lymphoma and other types of viruses
are known to have an
impact on both cancer development
survival of cells with particular damage
to their dna because of the viral
infection latent infection
and our ability to find specific strains
of viruses
that are specific to specific tumors
so we know that viruses co-evolve with
their hosts to establish stable
and co-regulated genomes and gene
expression programs
dna tumor viruses are distinguished by
their ability to provide
a selective growth advantage to host
cells
and typically establish long-term
persistent intracellular infection among
the most extensively characterized
uh human tumor viruses is abstain viral
virus
which has been implicated as a causative
agent in multiple b
cell lymphomas gastric carcinomas and
nasopharyngeal carcinomas
ebv is estimated to be responsible for
approximately one percent of all human
cancers
and may also contribute to other
disorders including multiple sclerosis
uh and others and while ebv oncogenes
and regulatory pathways have been
characterized individually
there have not been really comprehensive
stat studies that
examine the network of virus host
interactions at the
large-scale genomic scale genomic
integration
of data so one of the things that
has already emerged as an important
factor in our understanding tumors
is that in essentially when we call a
disease
cancer these are very heterogeneous
clinical conditions and even tumors
that we think of causing cancer and
leading to cancer prognosis
are very heterogeneous collections of
cells
and so when we think about that problem
tcga
and other data repositories even when
they are sequenced
as bulk rna represent a unique
opportunity to
study single cell profiles based on
what's called
single cell deconvolution and one of the
topics of this
upcoming training program with aims is
to introduce participants to tools
that allow us to have a glimpse at
single cell resolution of cancer
but obviously with the emerging emerging
technologies like
10x genomics and others we now have the
ability to process
and analyze in profiles of cancers
including distinguishing different cell
types
and the understanding of their
progression over time so what we will do
in this program
is introduce you to some of those tools
to really be able to ask
very detailed and specific questions
about
tumor heterogeneity the impact of
particular factors that we
associate with clinical outcomes and the
understanding of
drivers of particular types of changes
that are
typically associated with cancer now
another emerging area that i will
briefly speak of
because some of the collaborations that
our
company has been had having over the
years
is with cancer researchers that are
focused on
non-genomic regulation or what's called
epigenomic regulation
of cancer and one of those factors are
repeats
in the dna and as you can see here many
different types of sequencing approaches
allow us to understand the different
regulatory components of
junk or non-coding dna
that have an impact on cancer and in
fact have an
impact on biology of aging
cancer biology and virology so what we
hope
is that this is a glimpse into the world
of bioinformatics and this
bioinformatics
view of cancer provides you with
a landscape of rich and diverse types of
methods
to sequence understand and
apply the insights from data sets like
tcga
to the area of your interest so at this
moment
i will pass it on to dr mohit mizunder
to
speak about his the program itself
thank you ilya for this wonderful
overview and uh
i would now like to talk a little bit
about uh the program
how we are doing it how uh we are
conducting this what are the sessions
how
it's going to start so before that i
would like to
maybe briefly introduce myself so my
name is mohit mazumdar and
i did my masters and phd in
bioinformatics and learned to analyze
both sequence and structural data
so during the last few years i was
fortunate enough to collaborate and work
with several
research groups and could publish and
also
finish some of the research projects
that i was involved in so i continued my
journey as a bioinformatics expert and
joined companies
for bioinformatics projects that could
help pharma companies to do some
translational bioinformatics work
so after that i learned i joined pine
biotech where i interact with students
and researchers to help them analyze and
interpret complex biological data
and finish a research project
so let me just
change a little things here i'm having
some issues
right
so talking about today's program uh
that uh we have a design so this
workshop is designed with the help of
experts
who have worked on related projects
using the omix logic bioinformatics
training
so to briefly explain the omics logic
training so omixlogic is an integrated
educational and a research platform
where students and faculty can
learn conduct research and also
collaborate
so this platform combines introductory
coursework
on biological data analysis with data
management and analytical tools
so in this workshop uh our focus will be
to use analytical methods
and reference databases to study rna-seq
data and to understand how gene
expression
you know varies across many conditions
so we are going to start with the
understanding about the data itself
so to do this effectively what
bioinformaticians do is that they
leverage big data processing methods
that are organized into bioinformatics
pipelines
and they perform exploratory data
analysis
and then they apply different
statistical algorithms like normal
uh statistical tools like normalization
uh the different methods like hypothesis
testing
and then uh in this entire process we
will be also talking in the context of
how
big data plays a role in biomedical
research that regulates and that helps
us generate
data which uh in return helps us to
develop a hypothesis
that is then analyzed and used for
accurate improvement
and entire this entire process how this
is affecting
uh clinical care so i would wanted to
give you an
overview of this entire training process
so before we learn about the hands-on
tool that we are going to
show us today as a brief overview of big
data and machine learning
i would like to introduce the topics
that we will be covering this
uh friday and saturday
so on day one uh we have a list of
sessions that we will be doing
so it uh we will start with a welcome
message uh from our
from the organizer organizers and then
we will
be having a session starting by dr dr
malek dr samiranjan malik who is also
here and we'll invite him for
to say a few words as well so after that
we will be talking about
how rna sequencing is uh how do
we start from rna sequencing why do we
think about rna sequencing
what is the application of rna
sequencing then we will be having
another session
by uh by myself where i'll be talking
about the omics logic program and the
methods and all the access that the
participants will have
during this program so after that we
will be working with transcriptomics
data files
and we'll start uh doing the hands-on
analysis by doing pre-processing mapping
and quantification and dr harpreet
who is also here with us will be showing
you that
in a while so after that on the first
day we will be
learning about for the second phase
second session so after lunch
we will be meeting again and we will be
discussing how how can we
uh find pc data from tcga how to
download data from tcga
how to analyze start analyzing and
thinking about
about hypothesis from tcga data so after
that we will be looking into the data
itself
and that would again be another hands-on
session and after that hands-on session
we will be having a break
a little break uh and all this time then
we will be having this
these breaks uh you can definitely reach
out to us and ask any questions that you
have
during the session for the session and
we'll be assisting you and our team will
be there
and a team of mentors will be also there
to help you
during this uh learning uh through this
uh day one
so after that there will be an
opportunity to discuss
uh with the experts about your own
hypothesis the things that you want to
plan to do
are uh the research that you're
interested in
or the methods that you're interested in
learning so this entire process
using this entire process as i was
telling you that omics logic programs
are very unique because they cover a lot
of topics but we also provide a lot of
material that you can do and learn from
your own
so this online courses that we have uh
that the participants will have access
to freely
so what they will do what we will have
here is that
this this asynchronous resources that
will have
the entire tutorials ready for you that
you can download
and learn at your own pace as well so
overview of processing
statistical analysis machine learning
tools and also single
single cell data analysis techniques so
uh
in this in these uh tutorials you'll
find terminologies
all the basic concepts that you want to
start learning from
so that uh you feel like you know from
the beginning
till the advance stages so after that
the second day
would be about the research and working
with tcga data sets and project
proposals
and uh in this uh during this time we
will start with a review
and then uh dr malik will be talking
about
the micro rna data analysis
and then we will have another session
where we have presentations planned out
by
by interns and people who are working
with us on their research projects
then we will start learning about
machine learning and how machine
learning uh
or statistical analysis such as
classification and predictive analysis
is helpful in this
lymphoma data sets by looking at pcga
data sets and lymphoma data sets
how we can look into the data and
understand and build models maybe
predictive models or to find important
uh
signatures from that uh data set so we
will be doing the hands-on session
mostly all of the sessions will be
uh hands-on during this time except the
one for
uh at the time before lunch
so after that we will have uh research
uh opportunities and research projects
so we have already have a lot of
projects that you will be
seeing uh after this uh when dr harpreet
uh gives her presentation and then we
have the final
session where we'll be interacting with
you and we will be guiding you towards
the
resources that we have access to and
also giving you
uh idea of how to go next what are the
next steps
how can you conduct your own research
and how can you
analyze and you know write uh proposals
write grants
or maybe uh finish a publication so this
entire process
of doing this analysis starts from
like the exploratory analysis which
includes uh determining differentially
expressed
elements in known group of samples so we
have
also uh algorithms that we'll be using
like d6
hr and factor regression analysis to
understand these multiple factors and
then to find the biological meaning
so this entire methodology being applied
to large-scale data
with a defined research questions leads
to research projects
and recognition in the field so uh we
have several examples like olga here
uh who is a postdoctoral researcher at
at roswell park
cancer center and she used her
experience to learn about the data
analysis techniques
and she is now applying in her own
pre-clinical research
so another example is uh about a program
that we have so one of our
collaborator is dr sona vasudevan and
she is a professor at georgetown
university medical center
so she also is a director of system
medicine program there
so we held a workshop during uh this
during the summer and
and fall started our first pilot with a
batch of master students that led to
multiple research projects and
another other training programs for
students researchers high school
high school students so similarly we
have had a lot of
reviews from people at research who have
used the platform and used it for their
own analysis
for their own project similarly we are
working with research institutes
uh who are generating data i would want
to
take uh do collaboration for different
kind of analysis that could help them
uh find the uh meanings that hidden in
big data
so with this information uh i would now
like to invite
a dr harpreet guard to maybe show you
the the platform and also the projects
and how we are going to analyze some of
the data that we are discussing
so also uh please feel free to write in
the chat and i'll look into the chat for
any questions that you have so maybe
meanwhile when doctor
pleads start sharing maybe i can answer
a few questions
thank you dr mohit
so hello everyone my name is harpreet
kauf i have a phd
in bioinformatics in my current role i
am omix logic trainer and
a project mentor at pine biotic us
so let's first start and why we need to
do
study about cancer so as we know cancer
is one of the major concern worldwide
as per who report 20
2021 there are more than 18 million
cases are reported
every year for the cancer and
approximately
9.6 million people are dying due to the
cancer
so one out of the six that is only
because of the cancer
among these cancer breast breast cancer
lung cancer colon colon and bacter
prostate cancer
and stomach cancer among the major
cancer subtypes
based on the number of the incidence
while
lung cancer colon and rectal cancer
liver stomach and breast cancer are the
top cancer
subtypes based on the mortality rate
now already ilia is talk about the
cancer genome atlas
let me give you a bit more overview so
what is
tcga or the the cancer genome atlas so
tcpa
or what what in general we say the
cancer genome atlas it is of one of the
major pan-cancer project
which assemble data from thousands of
the patients
with primary tumor occurring in a
different tissue types
on the body and it approximately covered
33 cancer subtypes
a tcga alone contribute the data from
six
multi-omics layers that is rnac
whole exome mi rna sequencing
methylation
dna sequencing copy number variation
and then reverse phase protein array
data for nearly 33
uh different cancer which cover
approximately eleven thousand pesos
apart from the ngs or genomics data
tcga also encompass clinical and
demographic information
about these patients
so as we know and just genomics data is
continuously growing at exponential rate
there are number of key repositories
that maintain
this cancer multi-omics data so
let me give you the overview some of the
repositories
like the first uh initially the tcpa
data was
uh specially deposited in a specific
dedicated repository
but in a later on uh in the year 2016
so this tcga data is currently deposited
in different public repositories
one of them is gdc data portal or
genomic data
common common data portal so it is
this particular gdc data portal is
maintained by the
nci that is national cancer institute so
from the year 2016 onward
this gdc was launched uh as a pre-season
medicine initiative
so in integrate multi omics and clinical
data of large number of
cancer samples obtained from nearly 15
different cancer projects
and one of them one of that project is
tcc itself
so here the genomic data in the gdc is
harmonized
using uniform analysis pipeline to align
the raw sequencing data
to the genome particularly here they
have used
at j38 and then identified mutation gene
expression copy number alteration etc
based on the recent human genome so
here in the uh this uh here in this
repository
data is available for each single
patient sometimes
it is also difficult uh for a user
especially from non-computational
background
as it is not easy to process so then
there are some of other repositories
that actually start
maintaining process data one of them is
fire bros so what is the fire bros it is
a companion portal to the broad
uh broad institute gdac firehose
analysis pipeline
and watch tablet to curl and analyze the
data generated by the tcca
itself so it provides access to writing
of the cancer genomic data such as
clinical annotation annotated data
dna copy number variation m i r n e
mrne as well as uh it acts as a
comprehensive suit of more than 100
independent analysis tools so the major
advantage of fire draws
and some of the tools that i am going to
discuss later like see by a portal
is that it provides ready to use data
set metrics
which is useful for a user from
non-computational background
so then another data portal repository
which maintain tcga
data so that is c bio portal
so the c bio portal is again an open
access resource for
interactive exploration of
multi-dimensional cancer genomics data
sets
currently provide access to the data
more than 10
000 samples from 30 different cancer
studies so this particular c bio portal
significantly lower the variance between
the complex genomic data
and cancer research who want to rapid
initiative
and high quality access to molecular
profiles and clinical attributes from
large-scale cancer genomics projects
so then the another project that is gina
project and this is
another repository that is developed by
ucsc
so it is a visual uh visual exploration
resource
for both public and private omics data
supported through the web-based data
browser
and multiple turn by uh turnkey gina
hubs
so the unique architecture of this
server allows researcher to view their
own data securely
using private dns serve hubs and
simultaneously
one can explore the different you know
cancer genomics data
including they have also included tcca
data itself
so apart from the tcca data
there are important repositories that
ncbi is also available like
jio which maintain processed raw
and metadata lags of the patients
similarly if someone is interested to
analyze
or especially the raw data so then there
is a dedicated repository which is
sra or sequence read archive
uh which maintain raw sequencing data
so now let me show one of the recent my
recent review article
so here in this art review article
you will get a key information regarding
already available or mixed cancer data
resources
so similarly apart from uh this review
then there is another publication is
about
a resource for the cancer particularly
dedicated for the liver cancer
so this cancer level resource maintains
data set for nearly 10
000 liver cancer samples now let me
share the link for these publications
let's say if you are interested to learn
about what are already available omics
resources available
so this particular first is about the
review article
which encompass the information
regarding different public
repositories already available for the
cancer biomarkers
and the second this is if somebody
someone is interested to work on liver
cancer
so this particular publication provide
you
information regarding a dedicated
resource
so during this upcoming program you will
learn how we can actually retrieve data
from
these public repository so as we know
here we have raw sequencing data as we
know that we have only
raw uh like we have a samples of the
data
from uh thousands of our samples from
especially we have a raw data
so let's take an example here that i'm
showing you
here data is taken from a publication
which have a
raw rna seek data for the breast cancer
samples
so if we look at this data even a single
sample
is like a 6.2 gb
or more than 6 or 5 gb so
for example in your study you have 100
samples
so how you will manage that and process
that data to drive any biological
meaning from such data so challenge
challenges include handling storing
management and processing
of such data beside to process us
such data one must have some
computational skills
so to keep these challenges in mind
so we have designed our program as well
as here we have a ser
our server that is t-band for server
which not just provide user facility to
process and analyze such data
in addition it provides facility for the
user
from the non-computational background to
analyze
such a complex ngs data in a use
user-friendly manner by clicking on
options
so let me give you a demo how we can
generate a well-structured gene
expression data table
from the raw sequencing read data
so let me share link on of the server
okay so do we have a
credentials for the demo if we uh have
someone comes here and let me give you a
small demonstration how we can actually
process raw sequencing data to generate
a gene expression table
thank you vipsa for sharing the
credentials
so once you're able to log into this
server so if you are here
so you will after going into the server
you
must log in through these credentials
so once you are on the server let me
wait if someone able to login to the
server
just type yes if you are able to login
to t vibe for server
so here we are taking example from
breast cancer sample itself
so for the breast cancer samples we have
two subtypes that is er positive and
triple negative
so for that we have already uploaded our
raw sequencing data here
so under the ngs data here you will find
the first option that is transcript
transcriptomics so under the
transcriptomics the first pipeline that
is rna seek or chip parallel analysis of
ngs and microarray data here you will
find this drop down
so if you click on this drop down here
you will find
different example pipelines already so
here i am taking an example of demo rnac
pdx project so here what is this pdx
project is about
we have already two best cancer types
that are actually developed within a
waste and derived genograph genographs
so i am taking this example just to
demonstrate how we can actually process
originally well structured gene
expression table from raw sequencing ray
data
so as this is an example pipeline
so here we have already provided or
uploaded our data
so what we do by clicking on start
we able to upload this data so by
clicking on ok
you will uh find then you will be able
to upload that
data which is already uploaded here
so then uh once you uh
click on start then you will find
various options get highlighted
so here the first option that we are
going through
especially under the pre-processing so
once you uploaded your raw sequencing
three data
how those reads will get processed
here the first option which is getting
highlighted that is primo matic
so by clicking on primo matic this
pop-up will
come up so on this uh what this
chemomatic doing that it removes
adapter sequence from the raw these
so by clicking on ok we will able to
perform
pre-processing by trimomatic the next
option which is getting highlighted here
that is pcr clean
so what this pcr clean will do so
by uh clicking on pcr theme we will get
this
pop-up and here the pcr claim will
remove
any pcr duplicate reads
so once we able to do the pre-processing
the next
is how you know how you're going to
align your raw the uh
speeds on a reference a transcriptome or
reference genome
so here the next the options that are
getting highlighted that are under the
mapping
so if you look at all these algorithm
which highlighted here that are mapping
on genome and this one mapping on
transcriptome
as here our goal is to generate a gene
expression data table
that is rnac so what we are going to do
we are going to align our rate on
reference transcriptome so here the
algorithm that we are using that is but
i
two t so with the four two t
so this algorithm will align your reads
on a reference transcriptome so once
you're able to align your reads on
reference transcriptome the next is to
quantifying that
the expression of those transcripts so
here
under the uh this option expression
labels you will find one uh
this particular option get highlighted
that is rscm expression table
so here the algorithm what it does that
here we are using rsem algorithm
that will quantify your expression in
the form of
rpkm or fpkm values depending upon
whether your
these uh reads are single end or the
parent if you have pair and reads you
will be able to quantify your gene
expression in the form of
fb values so once the next option that
is getting highlighted in the
differential expression analysis right
now i am skipping this
as my goal is only to generate a gene
expression table
so by clicking on the end
we able to complete this pipeline
so once we able to complete this
pipeline you will get
or directed to this interface where you
will find output files
here if i just click on download
pipeline output file
you will find various output files here
the first
uh is zip folder which contain all the
files
followed by the mapping stats and then
you will find various x gene expression
files
so like here the gene expression fpm so
i am just downloading this gene
expression table
which contain the genes uh only those
genes
which have uh at least there are some
values across all the samples so
this particular the second the not
filtered file contain
all the genes uh it is not conceiving
whether your gene expressed in
all the samples or not so here we
downloading this file so now let me show
you what we have obtained from the raw
sequencing
data
so now let me paste this in excel file
now if you look at this file now here in
the columns we have samples
like here if i just show you the first
is er
then some sample id so er means that our
er positive breast cancer
while if you look at here onward so
from this call i column onward you will
find triple negative tn so that is
triple negative breast cancer
so then these are the samples in the
columns while if you look at
in the row you will find these are the
ensembl ids for the genes
so these are ensembl ids corresponding
to a particular gene
and these values are the fpk m values
so what does it mean for example for
this gene and in this sample this is how
much your
this particular gene expressed in this
particular sample
so this is the fbk value so the next
is once you have gene expression table
now you can perform various kind of
analysis
for example i'm just showing you a
simple example so if we
we just want to look at how this gene is
expressed right now i'm not normalizing
it
so i'm just looking at its fpk value
gene expression table
so i'm click copying this uh sample
names or sample ids
and i am copy this i'm also copying this
gene
so now once you have gene expression so
you can analyze
these this data to understand what is
the pattern of these genes
so for example here if you look at
this table uh this bar plot here what we
are
conceiving like here in the ear positive
sample based on the raw values
that is fpk and values so here we can
say this particular gene may be over
expressed in comparison
to the triple negative class this is how
once we have our data then we can
perform various kind of analysis
so as i am looking at complete gene
expression table so the next question
how i can analyze what is what are
different patterns within this data
so one way to do that to perform one of
the exploratory data analysis that is
unsupervised machine learning
that is principal component analysis
now let me take you again back to the
server and just show you how we can
perform various exploratory data
analysis
like i'm taking an example of pc itself
here under the data mining sections like
data integration and modeling here under
the data mining section you will find
various options like supervised analysis
method unsupervised utility factor and
differential expression
so let me give you an example from the
unsupervised
sorry under the utility here we have
demo utility pca pipeline
so here i'm just demonstrating you so
here again we have already uploaded this
gene expression table that we have
obtained
from this particular are any seek
pipeline
so the next is
once we start be able to upload that
table the next
uh the option which is getting
highlighted that is quantile
normalization
as i already told you we have spkm
values
especially to drive biological meaning
from the data
and uh next we are going to perform
normalization on our data so
we are here performing quantile
normalization so then after
you normalize your data as we know that
various kind of statistical
and uh machine learning can be applied
only
if data is normalized then the next
option which is getting highlighted
under the visualization so it is the
expiratory data analysis which is pca
so here we are performing principal
component analysis on this data
to understand what are different
patterns within our data based on these
gene expression table so by clicking on
and i'm able to complete this pipeline
particularly the pca pipeline
now if i click here
so here under the pdx so you will find
uh the pca result so i am just
downloading this particular results
right now
as well as this so already we have
uploaded now we have provided
these results so let me show you what
results that we have obtained
so after running the pca
you will get this kind of table so the
first
this table what it represent it
represent
how much variance is actually
represented by each component so for
example the first principal component
represents 30
variance in the data similarly the
second component represents
14 variance data so then to
uh if we draw the scatter plot for this
data
and to understand what uh what kind of
patterns it represent
so for example now i have no i can
actually add the labels but are here
positive samples of the triple negative
sample
so if i go to the select data now i need
to add
here positive samples so
need to write here positive sample and
here i just
need to provide what are my x axis for
the er positive i am taking
principle component 1 and what is my y
axis for the principal component 2
similarly for the triple negative group
so let me add the triple negative group
so here what is my x axis for the triple
negative samples
similarly what is my y axis for the
triple negative samples
now we can remove this we have only a
positive and triple negative sample then
you can look at
the pattern within your data so based on
this pixel we can clearly see
uh here positive samples which are
colored
red colored are distinct from the triple
negative sample which are green color
here we also find out this is one
outlier
so this is how explorative data analysis
help us to understand the pattern within
our data as well as to understand if
there are outliers so that we can remove
those outliers
to further perform any analysis
now let me go back to the presentation
so let now let me give you glimpse what
we are going to cover in our upcoming
workshop so first we will learn how we
can retrieve data from the
various public repository like tcga
geo under fire bros
and c bio portal so then we will learn
how we can perform
various types of exploratory data
analysis once we have a gene expression
table
so then to understand what are different
patterns within our data
using the t binfor server for example
here we can see
here we have different tumor we have a
samples from different tumor stages
like stage one stage two stage three
stays four
so like here based on the pca we can
look at these stages can be dismissed
from
each other so the next question once you
able to identify your groups
next how you can perform differential
gene expression analysis
uh to identify what are important genes
that make that may be making classify
both the different groups of the samples
so then
based on the daisy result you will try
to understand
how to identify the significant genes
between different groups
then how we can actually uh assign
a gene whether it is upregulated or the
down regulated based on the log to fold
change
or the p adjusted value and we will
learn about how we need to interpret
these results
so once you have already identified your
group
next uh in the second day
on the day two we will try to apply
uh supervised machine learning to
classify these classes of the samples
so here we will try to apply the
supervised machine learning and we will
try to understand how supervised machine
learning is different
from the unsupervised as well as
exploratory
uh statistical analysis and
you will also learn in which scenario
you can apply
unsupervised or statistical analysis and
in which scenario you can apply
supervised machine learning
so here to classify the samples we will
consider
different pathological or clinical
characteristics of the these patients
here we are going to take examples from
the liver cancer
as well as the lymphoma to understand
how we can classify
and these sample and how we can identify
important molecular signature
that can predict these clinical subtypes
of the
tumor so then we will also uh we will
demonstrate
how we can actually apply supervised
machine learning using t-band for server
so now to talk about how you can
register this workshop i would like to
pass this session to beepsup
so miss pipsa over to you if you have
any question i will look at the
questions in the chat box
thank you so much dr harpreet for that
overview
and the demonstration now i would want
to invite
dr sameeranjan malik from
all india institute of medical sciences
new delhi
to share his review of the workshop and
introduce you
to what we are going to cover again so
over to you dr malik thank you
thank you vape sir i like to share my
screen
my screen is visible yes dr malik yeah
good evening everybody good morning to
india so
they said i'm doctor swami ranjan malik
i'm associate professor department of
pathology
i deal with basically histopathology but
my
substantiality is lymphoma i look up
look after the
lymphometicular malignancy and the
second is the molecular pathway i have
an interest in molecular pathology i do
lots of molecular work
so um when i was in nebraska i came in
contact with this pine biome
where they are organizing whatsoever so
at that time i'm a very
newcomer like learning or next-gen
sequencing with prof
panda was our ex-head of the department
so though as explained by by the
previous heart faith and india
like it is a two part like one is sample
processing
one is data analysis right so
like popularly uh people used to say it
is their driveline
so you have to understand both are the
equal importance
dry lab is pipetting it is very
streamlined if you know pipetting
know your kit then you can do
so but after you do your like sequence
you get a huge number of data so what to
do with the data
so now it is very easy to if you go uh
if you see the cost of ngs over the
period of time
if you go to uh from human genome
project 2.7 billion this is a very
popular slide everybody is
in a changes lecture so now it is almost
less than 1000 usd
if you are in india if you go for any
outsourcing it cost hardly 30 000 if you
do whole
exam even a full whole transcriptome
whole genome may cost a few
or more more but hardly 30 000
and everybody has a project at least
i can say i'm working in ams in our
department many people have a project
they all of them almost all based upon
like high thoroughford data either a ngs
or a microarray
right so you get very easy to get get it
done from outsourcing
and many people also outsource by the
wetland part
so billy when it comes to bioinformatics
nobody will going to suffer
these companies they will say they will
give you the data with
some minimal workup like some over
express
games someone down experience or just a
normal life
so this is a very uh popular uh graph uh
like for popular picture in 2000
early 2000 so when this human genome
project came
so it's by bill clinton now everybody is
very happy
so how we know how god wrote the book of
the life
because now the human genome project is
out the database is there there are
rotated around 25 to 30 000 genes
everybody knows but it's not really too
easy
how many of you uh if you go to indian
vedic's astrology
this is what you will get if you put
your data back you'll get this kind of
chat and whoever believes in
like this astrology it can give you lots
of information this how is that out but
how many
are able to understand you can't
understand these things unless until
you don't know how to read the book it's
just like if you
outsource your like weight sample or if
you process your
like weight lab you'll get a data it's
just like you have to purchase a book
from
a market but if you don't know how to
read the book by the same thing
if you are doing a whole exam sequencing
yes if you are going to know
for your loan amputated variant you can
just the company will say yes this is
the variant you know
and these are the mutated but apart from
that you have a huge number of data how
to
deal with that data
so ngs and what's about the weight lab
weight lab like
now if you go to the iron torrent iron
drawing platform which platform are
in our department we have impgem and
proton and we work on this platform i am
more acquainted with
there are two basic platforms where
people are working one is illumina one
is
uh iron torrent platform either pgm or
proton or
s5 and if you go to uh this platform now
they have come up with a machine concept
io which can you just put your dna
they will prepare your chip and you have
to load the chip
so now this the wetland somehow
been what called robotic
or now it's a machine is going to do for
you you don't have to too much bother
about that
but whatever this buy information huge
data
you will get at least if you go for a
whole you know
whole genome it is around 3gb data for a
for a single x one it
it will go for a whole exam it is comes
around 30 mb data
so how to deal with data then again you
have to do at least 100 x depth
so you have a huge data so how to deal
with this data so you have to have it
like what called balance between a wet
lab and dryer
so why i fascinated with this platform
as a very new very uh like naive in the
ngs
data analysis was like wet lab dry lab
then i attended a few whatsapp of honda
interact with india also in nebraska
university of nebraska then i came to
know okay you don't have to learn these
uh
linux uh things or are
this language very deep language you can
have like
uh if you know which pipeline if you
know which uh software
uh if you can establish your own
pipeline
then it's okay you can go ahead and use
the pipeline and can pay
few things like you can take the most
part i like in this pine bio you can
take
for one month if you have a only small
data
you can take for one month and finish
your job you don't have to take for
like one year so on
the equal importance of wet lab and dry
lab
or bioinformatics so the bioinformatic
is much
more important now a time then you are
doing the sample processing and for
example
like i'm more of a histopathologist i'm
not a basic scientist right
or whatever there are many people work
done very
closely like scientists i have to do the
clinical work i have to do this research
so for me
at least you should know what you are
doing like what your data come up with
so what pipeline you are using otherwise
if you just
outsource your thing then you will get
only few annotated variants what you are
known or only thing like your express
genes downloaded genes
this much only so there is a unique
opportunity for you people to come up
and know how you analyze your data
like uh just before few days uh
a couple of projects from my qr analysis
i
think help of these fine bio people and
we have
a very meaningful data for the last six
months we are struggling how to come up
with this data how to analyze
but did this i use this platform this is
really helpful
so hope uh in this whatsapp
so basic uh when we're planning
how to what should be the topic and what
should we are the student will be
helpful
and when we are designing this
this total schedule we have keeping keep
in mind like we should
give equal importance to dry lab and
wetland
so hope this this will be too easy for
you people to understand
and there's a complete with this dr
harper dr mohit
uh and uh other speakers from the
fine bio will help you out for your
queries and there are two databases
which are selected by uh dr harpoon we
are going to discuss one with lymphoma
or his labor
and people also during the chat session
or the mentoring session if you can
discuss your own data it could be your
own data you can discuss with us
thank you vipsa thank you so much
uh dr malek one more thing i like to
highlight like
the rna
just a few seconds rna-seq
sample processing is going to cover by
dr
gupta is from officer but unfortunately
he came forward positive and
hospitalized student so we are
uh looking for us for better concept
so hopefully we will get some speaker to
have a good idea regarding the sample
processing or may we may have to drop
but we are still working on this
so all knows this is the situation in
right now what india is not a good one
of a huge number of cases
but still in this pandemic you will get
we have a unique opportunity to learn
your
this data analysis from the spine bio
and also here
i'll try to clarify whatever the things
i have learned from
[Music]
in the last five to six years thank you
thank you so much
so i want to talk about
the outcome of attending this two-day
webinar
once you have attended this webinar you
will be able to use
advanced statistical analysis and
machine learning methods
that we have described and discussed in
today's session
to explore and find patterns in data
leading to noble biomarker discoveries
and associations between molecular
pathways and clinical manifestations
and of course at the end of this two-day
webin
webinar and workshop you will also
receive a certificate of participation
now i want to show everybody how to
register
and as well as introduce you to some of
the
processes of getting accustomed to the
resources that are there so first
resource that i wanted to share with you
is the registration for this two day
workshop so this is the link
to register for the workshop i will be
posting it in the chat you have to
make sure that you're clicking here and
then you will be taken
to the page i'm sorry that this should
be showing
some kind of problems
okay so what we can also share with you
is a different payment link for anyone
who is in india so you can also do
left payment we can sell you the details
for that the cost is
2 000 inr for anybody who wants to join
this
workshop who is outside of india
please reach out to us so that we are
able to help you out in that process
and we can make sure that you have the
right links in case this is not working
we will be sending out a separate neft
account again
where you can use google pay or paytm or
some of these other options so please
reach out to me regarding this
and next i wanted to introduce everybody
to the comics logic resources that you
can start using
and also learning from as well as how to
gain access to the tbi or
platform that dr harpreet demonstrated
today
so if you're here with me please come to
the learn
dot omics logic portal so i'm already
logged in
here so let me log out and log
back in to this portal just to show
everybody
how things are going to work so i
already have
created an account and you can already
see my
email id here and a password
if you are creating an account for the
first time
then what you would receive is an email
from our team
dev pine dot bio regarding how to set up
your t bio info account so with that
reset link you will be able to gain
access to tbi info in case
again if you are having any issues
please feel free to reach out to me
and i will be able to help out with that
and once you are logged into the
platform you will come across
a lot of these different courses and
projects so
one of the first projects that you would
see is the tcga liver cancer project on
precision oncology now this free level
of
learn dot omics logic will give you
access to
a number of courses and projects and
mostly you would be able to overview
a lot of the courses for free
if you are interested in taking
or learning more you would have to take
up
a participation in one of our omics
logic programs or workshop like this to
avail
all of the resources that require a
subscription
okay and what i wanted to show you next
are what are the opportunities that
doing an omics logic program or a
workshop offers for you
so i will take the example of some of
our recent
graduates of our bioinformatics research
programs and also paste this link here
in the chat box with everybody so that
you can also review this link
so these are some of the research
projects
that have been completed by our research
fellows
and you can see that these projects have
been done by the participants themselves
these participants come from a very
mixed group starting from
high school students to researchers who
have worked on
several different topics so as i was
mentioning at the start of today's
session that we welcome
everybody to share about their area of
interest and help us understand how we
can
work with you to help you complete that
project or
assist you with tools that can actually
less i mean like you know decrease the
amount of time that would
require for you to complete a project so
these projects have been completed in a
period of three months or six months
so you see that's a very small amount of
time
for a project usually projects take a
lot longer time require a lot more work
but while working with data sets which
are available in public repositories
like ncbi or tcga as dr harpreet has
been showing
you can then start using tools like the
tbi info cloud server
and find out the meaning behind those
data sets to answer
a particular kind of biological question
that you're trying to answer so
here are some of these projects for your
review
and we are also very proud of our
previous research fellows who have
now finally published their pre-prints
here and you can read all about them
right here
so this one is by our
research fellow urja parikh where she's
learning about glioma
and glioblastoma and the next is
by our other research fellow
who is the lara dicken from the
university in turkey bachelor university
so she was studying the radiation threat
to humans in space
and by taking an alternative approach
with probiotics it's a metagenomic
project so please feel free to go
through these
projects we have also been collaborating
with the nokuji
uni memorial institute at the university
of
ghana and with them we have this poster
i will be sharing this
video link with you in the chat box
again and of course we will be emailing
you all of these
links so that you can have a look at the
research that we are doing
with our collaborators as well as the
participants who join programs like this
and work with us
in all of our bioinformatics community
along with our mentors
so you can learn more about the posters
how these projects are done and
everything is
done right from where you are so if you
have a computer system
and an internet connection you can get
started today so
if you are a student who is not yet
exposed to such
tools you can still get started with
a project like this first by starting to
learn from some of these resources that
are mentioned here
so these courses are the starting so let
me just show you the first post that we
hope everybody should start with is this
introduction to bioinformatics course
and this will give you an overview of
why bioinformatics is useful and
how is it applicable to areas like
healthcare and other sciences and how
you can you know learn more about it and
apply it to your own research
so this is definitely one course that we
recommend to everybody and then you are
free to go ahead and explore any of
these courses that are here and we are
definitely going to be covering a lot of
those
in the upcoming workshop as well as our
other omixlogic programs
and again if you're having any problem
with
access to the tbi or info platform
please email me at marketing and find
dot bio and i will be able to take a
look
at that i also wanted to
invite everybody to take a look at some
of the other free webinars that we have
tomorrow so the next free webinar that
we have tomorrow
is on an enterovirus d68
outbreak that again you are welcome to
join
and we do hope that you would of course
be joining
the upcoming workshop that is starting
on april 23rd and 24th dr mohit
has given you an overview of the entire
workshop session so please feel free
again to
review this video and i also welcome you
to come and join our social media groups
we have a number of
bioinformaticians researchers and
students like you who are part of these
groups on our social channels where you
can join
and interact with them and
learn more about what everybody else is
doing so these are our two groups on
facebook and linkedin
if you again have any questions i
welcome you all
to go ahead and ask us any of these
questions again at marketing and find
out bio
and for everybody who is looking forward
to joining the
transcriptomic data analysis for
precision oncology session starting on
april 23rd you can reach out to me and
we will also be emailing everybody the
details especially related to left
transfer or any of those other necessary
details that is required
and i thank you all again for joining
today's session we hope
it was informative if you have again any
any questions or any feedback please
feel free to write to us
and we hope to see you at our upcoming
sessions and upcoming workshop we wish
you all
a wonderful evening and a wonderful day
ahead for everybody else in the other
time zones so thank you all again for
attending today's session
have a wonderful day just a few words to
the students from ams who want to attend
if there's any problem they can contact
directly to my lab
me or dr president is also here they can
contact me or
dr prasad anybody regarding the payment
issue or any other clarification
thank you thank you dr malik yeah sure
so anybody who is from
ames and wants to join the workshop you
can directly get in touch with dr malik
or dr prashant
and for everybody else who would want to
join the workshop please
feel free to reach out to me at
marketing and find out bio and i can
guide you with the joining processes and
the
definite session details if you need
further help
thank you all again for joining today's
session
we hope to see you in the upcoming
webinar and the workshop
have a nice day everybody
you